the jurogan experience there seems to be
a direct connection between the loss of
faith in the military in those conflicts
the korean conflict and then the vietnam
conflict whereas we don't think about it
that way when we think about world war
ii when we think about world war ii we
think about it as the good guys versus
the bad guys and you know we we won and
we came back and there's the the famous
kiss on you know on v-day where you know
in the middle of the street you know
there's like there's all these romantic
notions attached to world war ii that
aren't attached to korea and aren't
attached to vietnam yeah yeah i mean
eisenhower speech people pull out that
military-industrial complex
but people should listen to the whole
speech listen to it and watch it yeah
because it's fascinating but something
shifted and i don't know exactly what it
is i can't put my finger on it but it
keeps coming back to accountability but
my question is why do we lose that sense
of accountability why did we lose the
importance of accountability following
world war ii particularly in 1947 when
we reorganized really our defense
the intelligence agencies and the
military got reorganized in 1947 we
changed the name of the war department
to the department of defense so we have
precision in language precision and
thought uh there's a shift there we used
to have a secretary of war what do we
have after 1947 we have a secretary of
defense so this look there's there's
that little thing little thing but
language is important
and then for some reason we stopped
holding our senior level leaders
accountable and uh and i don't know why
you could point to uh this essentially a
triad or um
of of politicians of think tanks of the
defense industry uh and kind of how
people float between all those things
yeah um so it became big business nato
became big business um so there's
there's a lot of things that came into
play that weren't at play before world
war ii um that become reality after
world war ii so i don't know what it is
i can't put my finger on it but then we
have that same generation that came home
and what did they do they got to work
they had they didn't whine about what
they'd been involved in they got to work
and they built this country into what it
is today and uh and
it's so hard to see what we're doing to
ourselves really in this country that
last book in the uh the devil's hand i
put myself in the enemy's shoes and i
thought hey what have they learned from
us on the field of battle over the last
20 years at war and uh during the time i
was writing that cove would hit summer
of civil unrest very contentious
political season an election cycle the
enemy's learning from all those things
and the the sad part of my takeaway from
that research was that hey if i'm the
enemy i might just watch we're doing a
pretty good job of destroying ourselves
from the inside yeah right now i might
just just wait and watch and see what
happens um but of course i had to figure
out in a in a fictional sense how to
deal with that and i did in a very
creative way that i that was was fun to
figure out but uh but it's sad to think
that we've lost this appreciation i
think for what was sacrificed so we
could have these freedoms and options
and opportunities that we do today so
from the inception of this country up
until today people have sacrificed
everything or they've risked everything
so that we could have these freedoms and
now we have a segment of society that
wants to undercut those freedoms because
i don't think they appreciate what was
sacrificed so we could have them uh and
that part's that's sad i took my
daughter to um pearl harbor for the 80th
anniversary commemoration events this
last december and uh we volunteered with
an organization called the best defense
foundation donnie edwards foundation
that takes people back to the world war
ii battlefields primarily so they can
say goodbye they can make peace with
what they what they did there and a lot
of them it's their last trips to these
places a lot of them it's their second
trip the first one was actually going
over the beach in normandy or going to
iwo jima and fighting and now they're
getting to go there in the last years of
their lives and say goodbye
but we went to pearl harbor and so my
daughter is 16 and she sat we
volunteered we took 64 veterans age of
96 to 104. wow and in wheelchairs we're
getting them on and off the buses taking
them to the events getting the dinners
making sure they're taking their
medications all that stuff and it was a
turning point in her life because she
got to sit down across the table from
this generation that yeah she's heard me
talk about and she's read about but to
hear them tell their stories and a lot
of them haven't even told their stories
until just a few years ago
there's one guy jack holder who was on
the airfield at pearl harbor he watched
the planes japanese planes come over the
mountains drop down strafe the runway he
jumps into this what was then a sewage
ditch and he showed us the the bullet
holes in the runway still there in the
hangar still there and so he jumps into
the sewage dish he watches the planes
take this left-hand turn bank and he
jumps up runs to the edge of of the of
pearl harbor right there on the water
and watches them and watches the first
torpedoes get dropped in pearl harbor
and then he went back he flew a pby
which was a
seaplane
and then he went on to uh to fight in
the pacific and he sunk a uh a japanese
submarine and helped sink a japanese
aircraft carrier and then he goes to the
mediterranean and sinks a uh a german uh
submarine i mean incredible incredible
that's what this generation did for us
and so she got to see that but so she
appreciates point being is that she
appreciates what those gender generation
gave us and then by default what
previous generations have given us so uh
we're gonna go to d-day here um this
june taking her out of school we're
gonna go do that and go to uh normandy
and uh take the same group of veterans
back to back to normandy and a lot of
them it'll be their their last trip um
but uh she'll get to help again get them
to the events get them to dinners get
them on and off the buses in and out of
the wheelchairs and and experience uh
that place with them i can't imagine
what it must be like for them to go back
to normandy and to be on that beach
and i mean i've seen the photographs and
you know i think probably uh one of the
best uh theatrical representations of it
is saving private ryan right which is
horrific
how do you imagine that they they nailed
that scene oh yeah oh yeah i mean it's
it's uh god it puts things in relative
terms and for me it was in buds on the
beach in hell week you know doing
push-ups getting yelled at you're
freezing you're on the verge of
hypothermia people are quitting and i
thought hey you know what i'm not coming
off of a boat on to a beach in normandy
where i'm running through a hail of
machine gun fire that's set up in an
elevated position with no cover and
concealment between me and that position
right i'm like i can do a few more
push-ups here on the beach you know i
can shiver here in the water a little
longer here those guys sacrificed that
so i could follow my dream and i could
be here on this beach in coronado
california testing myself in this
crucible of buds so i think about that
that generation in particular uh quite a
bit and uh and what they gave us
tactically when they review storming the
beach at normandy is there alternative
methods of approaching that situation
that people have proposed that would
have been
caused less casualties because it's such
a crazy thing to just dump everybody off
at the beach and run towards the gunfire
i mean yeah i will always wonder like
how why didn't we why didn't they do
something differently why didn't they
shoot at them with planes and soften
them up first i mean it seems
well we had some of that so we did drop
a
drop people behind the lines we had
gliders going in
we bombarded the shore gliders is
because no no sound
you know that is a good i mean that must
be a part of it i can't remember exactly
why but that must be that must be it but
yeah the gliders going in and oh my gosh
what i mean a crazy
thing to be involved in just in the
especially back then yeah in the 1940s
being in the back of a glider
essentially crashing and getting out and
then having to figure out where you are
and then to figure out without radios
who the good guys are who the bad guys
are which direction are we going like
all of that so we get dropped off in the
right place right um some of some were
shot down and then they you know a lot
of them were shot down um but uh so they
did do things they did do things to
soften up those those those beaches and
and all of that but you know we're
dealing with 1940s technology coming off
of lessons of world war one which was
even more horrific
um
did they have missiles back then that
are capable of uh like being precise
or did they just sort of launch them in
the general direction yeah the germans
had some uh misalignment i believe they
had missile technology that was a rocket
technology that was um far superior to
ours i think people can check me on that
but no it's mostly like a gigantic
bullet coming out of a battleship wow
and uh and hitting something or not um
so yeah it's an amazing place to go for
people who haven't been to go to these
memorials especially to take kids to
these memorials and go to pearl harbor
and to go to normandy and to go stand up
on pointe du hoc and look down and see
hey where the rangers had to climb up
ropes and ladders and the germans are
firing right down on them from these
positions and they just kept climbing uh
the longest day that old movie um it
shows that as well and i grew up with
that film it's an old black and white
movie that people should watch they
should watch that end saving private
ryan but uh and that's the power of
popular culture like these movies play
an important part in uh in in our
popular culture and in our history
because you can show these things and
create this appreciation and we're just
losing that i think i mean hollywood
used to be our most uh uh most prolific
and valuable asset that we would export
and so people from all over the world
would see these movies and see this
opportunity that was the united states
and i think that's shifted that's
shifted over time but uh that's why
those war films i think are so important
because you can watch that and say oh my
gosh i am so appreciative of what those
guys did yeah you know what my life here
maybe i should uh make it maybe i can
make some changes here and i can uh
appreciate what they did for us so that
i can have make my own decisions and uh
and i can have these freedoms and
opportunities rather than just complain
about it because really you know what
i'm not doing running into a hail of
machine gun bullets as i cross this
beach so there's there's a lot to be an
appreciative to appreciate the
previous generations what they did for
us